cámara senado y gobernaciones no son las
únicas decisiones que Define el pueblo
estadounidense hay varios temas clave
para el futuro del país en juego
presentes en las boletas a modo de
refrendos algunos de estos se centran en
el uso de la marihuana y el derecho al
aborto cuatro estados California Vermont
Michigan Y el conservador Kentucky le
dieron el Sí al aborto uno de los temas
centrales en la batalla electoral la
reacción del centro de derecho se
reproductivos concede en Nueva York no
se hizo esperar
Victoria los votantes de California
Kentucky Michigan y Vermont votaron a
favor de proteger el acceso al aborto en
sus estados lo que supuso una victoria
sísmica para los derechos reproductivos
los votantes han hablado y han dejado
claro lo que creen el aborto es
imprescindible la legalización del uso
recreativo de la marihuana es otro de
estos temas de los cinco estados en los
que se discutió la propuesta el no se
impuso en Arkansas Dakota del Norte y
Dakota del Sur Mientras que el sí ganó
en Mary Missouri simplemente muestra que
este no es un tema partidista Esto es
algo que trasciende las divisiones
partidistas el no al trabajo forzado
para individuos condenados en
determinados delitos estuvo también
sobre la mesa electoral en Tennessee
Luisiana Vermont Alabama y Oregón según
las proyecciones de medios
estadounidenses se aprobaron estos
cambios en las constituciones estatales
alababa votó además la sustitución del
lenguaje racista de su Constitución
mientras que evermod incluyó en su Carta
Magna territorial que la esclavitud y la
servidumbre involuntaria están
prohibidas para siempre en el estado los
cambios no se verán de inmediato en las
prisiones dado que puede impulsar varios
pleitos judiciales California el estado
más poblado de Estados Unidos preguntó a
su ciudadanos si legalizaban las
apuestas en el ámbito deportivo o
hacerlas personalmente en casinos
gerenciados por tribus indígenas ambas
propuestas Se recibieron un no rotundo
las armas también experimentaron un
rechazo profundo en Oregón estado que
aprobó el endurecimiento de las leyes
deporte